OUR NEXT GUEST, "THE DAILY
SHOW'S" JORDAN KLEPPER HAS BEEN
SPEAKING TO VOTERS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY'VE SAID TO
HIM.
>> THE MOST BEAUTIFUL THING I
EVER SAW, THOUSANDS, MAYBE A
MILLION PEOPLE GATHERED, SO
QUIET.
IT WAS A PEACEFUL RALLY.
>> JANUARY 6th?
>> JANUARY 6th.
>> BIRDS CHIRPING, POLICE
OFFICERS SCREAMING?
>> NO.
>> SOME OF THEM WERE ATTACKED
THAT DAY.
>> THEY WERE?
>> DID YOU NOT SEE THE VIDEOS?
>> I COULDN'T WATCH IT.
>> WHY IS THAT?
>> WE WERE AT HOME WATCHING ON
TV WHAT HAPPENED, I SAID TURN
THAT OFF.
THAT IS NOT WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
>> YOU DIDN'T SEE ANY VIOLENCE?
>> NO.
>> WHEN YOU WEREALITY HOME, YOU
TURNED IT OFF.
>> IT WASN'T TRUE.
NOT AN ACCURATE DESCRIPTION.
>> WAS IT MAGIC GEORGE LUKE KS
SHIT?
>> COULD BE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> THE "THE DAILY SHOW'S" JORDA
CLEP PER JOINING US.
>> IT WAS PLAYING OUT.
>> A GREAT EXAMPLE, WHAT SHE SAW
WAS PEACEFUL.
I DON'T DOUBT IT THAT THERE WERE
POINTS OF THE DAY THAT WERE
PEACEFUL FROM HER PERSPECTIVE.
WHEN CONFRONTED WITH INFORMATION
THAT COULD CHANGE HER MIND, SHE
TURNED IT OFF.
THAT'S IT IN A NUTSHELL.
>> YOU DON'T SEE WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU TURN IT OFF AND DON'T WATCH
IT.
>> YES, YES.
WE'VE BEEN TAUGHT YOU CAN LIVE
IN YOUR OWN BUBBLE IF YOU CHOOSE
TO.
I THINK SHE WAS GETTING
INFORMATION THAT SHE DIDN'T
LIKE.
SO SHE HAS ABILITY TO RETAIN
THAT IMAGE.
THAT'S THE IMAGE SHE'S GOING TO
VOTE WITH.
>> I LOVE THIS.
YOUR TEAM DID AN EXTRAORDINARY
JOB.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK TO GO TO ALL
THESE STATES, ALL THESE EVENTS,
GET THESE PEOPLE TO TALK TO YOU.
THEY DID.
WHAT WAS STUNNING FOR ME, AND
SHE'S AN EXAMPLE OF IT, IS HOW
MANY PEOPLE STILL BELIEVE THESE
ELECTION LIES.
THERE ARE REPUBLICANS IN OFFICE
WHO ARE SHOOTING IT DOWN, BUT
THERE ARE ALSO REPUBLICANS
RUNNING LIKE RON JOHNSON IN
WISCONSIN WHO ARE PERPETUATING
THEM STILL UP AHEAD OF TOMORROW.
HOW DANGEROUS DO YOU THINK IT IS
FOR THESE PEOPLE WHO HAVE THESE
BELIEFS NOT TO HAVE THEM
CORRECTED BY SOME IN THEIR OWN
PARTY?
>> I THINK THE ADULTS IN THE
ROOM ARE ACTING LIKE CHILDREN.
YOU CAN CRAFT YOUR OWN REALITY.
I EXPECTED TO GO OUT THERE AND
TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED THE
LAST ELECTION, WHETHER THEY
ACCEPTED THAT.
I WAS SURPRISED HOW MANY PEOPLE
AREN'T ACCEPTING WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
WHEN YOU HAVE ADULTS WHO ARE
LIKE, YOU DON'T NEED TO BELIEVE
WHAT HAPPENED WITH WIDEN/TRUMP.
WHAT SHOULD I BELIEVE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN A
WEEK, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TOMORROW?
ALREADY FOLKS TOLD ME I'M NOT
GOING TO BELIEVE IT IF I DON'T
LIKE IT.
>> IF I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> IF I DON'T GET WHAT I WANT, I
DON'T HAVE TO ACCEPT IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WON'T BE HAPPY
TOMORROW BECAUSE THEY WON'T LOSE
BECAUSE THEY CHOOSE TO ACCEPT
IT.
>> JORDAN IS MAKING FUN OF THESE
PEOPLE, BUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
ASKING THEM QUESTIONS AND
THEY'RE ANSWERING ON THEIR OWN.
DO YOU FEEL -- I DON'T KNOW --
SORRY -- HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ANSWERING
YOU?
THEY ARE ADULTS, BUT THEY'RE
BEING CO-OPTED BY, AS YOU SAID,
PEOPLE IN THE ROOM THAT ARE
ADULTS BUT ACTING LIKE CHILDREN.
>> I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE WANT TO
BE A PART OF A MOVEMENT.
THEY WANT A COMMUNITY, A SENSE
OF MEANING.
YOU GO TO A LOT OF THESE EVENTS
AND YOU HAVE POLITICIANS WHO
GIVE THEM A SENSE OF A MEANING.
THEY TELL THEM THEY'RE A PATRIOT
AND TO FIGHT.
THEY'RE AROUND LIKE-MINDED
PEOPLE.
I EMPATHIZE WITH WANTING TO BE A
PART OF THOSE THINGS.
I THINK IT'S SCARY BECAUSE IT'S
BEING MANIPULATED BY PEOPLE WHO
SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
ALL I'M DOING IS TRYING TO GET A
LAY OF THE LAND, WHAT DO YOU
ACTUALLY BELIEVE?
WHAT IS SINKING IN?
IT'S NOT SINKING IN --
>> IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN DO
OR SAY, ANY FACT, IF YOU SHOW
THEM THE VIDEO -- THE ONE WOMAN
SAID I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO WATCH
IT LIVE ON TV EVEN THOUGH YOU
CAN SEE THE REALITY.
IS THERE ANYTHING --
>> FACTS MOVE SLOW, BS MOVES A
LOT FASTER.
FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE THE BEST
SHOT.
>> HOW LONELY IS IT ON THE
GROUND WHEN YOU TALK TO THESE
PEOPLE AND THEY BELIEVE IT?
>> IT'S EXHAUSTING.
I'M CONSTANTLY SURPRISED BY HOW
FAR THESE NARRATIVES CHANGE AND
MOVE.
I WENT TO ONE EXPECTED TO TALK
ABOUT ROE V. WADE, AND WITHIN
MINUTES I'M TALKING TO OLDER
WOMEN IN WISCONSIN WHO ARE
TALKING ABOUT JFK JUNIOR BEING
ALIVE AND THE VICE PRESIDENT.
AS A COMEDIAN, IT'S SHOCKING AND
HUMOROUS AT TIMES.
I THINK THE EXHAUSTION COMES
FROM JUST HOW QUICKLY WE MOVE
WITH OUR WISHFUL THINKING.
>> JORDAN, THANK YOU FOR THIS.
IT'S FUN ANYPLACE AND THAT'S THE
POINT OF THIS, BUT IT'S SO
DISTURBING.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY VERY EYE
OPENING BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
TRUTH THERE, AND I THINK IT'S
EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO DIGEST.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.